haha the Joe Rogan experience did I ever
tell you that story which one I think
one time after I did one of your
podcasts a guy hits me up on Instagram I
was like hey so excited that you're
doing jiu-jitsu man I make mouth guards
I want to make you a personal mouth
guard that's great man he goes what do
you want on it I go oh I know exactly
what I want on it so I tell him what I
want and he sends it Paula I get I could
I get to the Academy and then go JJ I
kind of mouth guard he was good you're
gonna need it and then I put it in and I
got on the mat and I smile and he goes
ah why do you want coming your mouth
okay what he goes boy it means come I go
why do you say it all the time
it doesn't mean it when we say it but
that's actually what it means like it
means a bunch of things yeah but the
actual word means comment oh my god [ __ ]
I never wore the thing again but it
means different things like like Gilbert
Burns
who's fighting tomorrow you smile for
the title he always yells it after he
wins he wins yells PAH
yeah because they they use it like that
but it means different things but it's
the same way Malacca means jerk-off and
in Greek but they'll say today Milo what
are you doing hey how you been my logo
it's like that's like the Joey Diaz
thing you call you jerk-off yeah but it
doesn't mean it you know I mean but the
actual meaning of this apparently is
[ __ ] common it's like it's laughing
hysterically - you ever see Jack laugh
like that it's pretty [ __ ] funny hey
why don't you go put the comeback in so
if the guys listening who made me the
mouthpiece can you make me another one
that just says my name's yes just deal
would come in your mouth bro girls been
dealing with it for years you know just
handle it
and like a [ __ ] gentleman yeah
[Applause]